qui n'a pas pesté devant sa messagerie
électronique en panne d'accès internet
impossible de téléphone à prix réduit
qui ne fonctionne pas le nombre de
plaintes visant des fournisseurs d'accès
à internet au téléphone et au câble ne
cesse d'augmenter les plaintes les plus
fréquentes concernent la qualité de
fonctionnement les interruptions du
service les difficultés d'installation
en tête
alice suivi par free bruno timsit et
mathias second les nouvelles
technologies c'est bien quand ça
fonctionne
c'est ce que se disent de plus en plus
de consommateurs dans sa l'association
on recense les plaintes les dossiers
s'accumulent plus 50% par rapport à
l'année dernière
les plus mécontents ce sont les clients
des opérateurs internet les accepte des
nouveaux abonnés oui et c'est
probablement normal mais elle n'y a pas
derrière les moyens pour assurer une
qualité suffisante entre lannion les
joues à mal les courriels on y répond
pas le courrier encore moi là on appela
de deux genres qui se plaignent de ce
genre de choses
parmi les plaintes les plus fréquentes
la qualité de fonctionnement les
difficultés de livraison et
d'installation et même les interruptions
de service au hit parade des opérateurs
les plus critiques et alice est en tête
devant free et club internet
al'inverse c'est orange qui compterait
le plus de clients satisfaits internet
et téléphonie un marché en pleine
expansion mais pas encore au point
les opérateurs plaide l'erreur de
jeunesse vous verrez que dès cette année
le nombre de plaintes par ligne va
commencer à diminuer parce que nous
serons un marché plus mature avec des
opérateurs qui auront en effet appris à
jara à servir leurs clients au mieux des
besoins de ceux ci
le mois dernier devant l'afflux de
plaintes nous avait été mise en demeure
par les pouvoirs publics de régler les
litiges qui l'opposent à ses clients
l'opérateur s'est engagé à traiter tous
les dossiers avant la fin du mois de
mars